- Hi Jonah.
- Hi Drew, it's wonderful
to see you again.
How are you?
- Oh, Jonah,
I can't have a week go by
where we're not hanging out.
I mean, since 2019 and you and I decided
to go on this journey together,
I am just so thrilled to be here.
Okay, Jonah, let's get
right into the news.
You have some T-Rex information?
- Oh yes, today I'm reporting on a story
that there's now a dinosaur named Stan,
and he is the most complete
T-Rex fossil that there is,
and is actually in Rockefeller Center.
And it's about to auction on October 6th
for six to $8 million,
and I really want it.
(Drew laughs)
I did the math, and it
would take 35,000 afghans
by October 6th, but I really want it.
So could you take a picture of
it for me and send it to me?
Since it's right there
in Rockefeller center?
- Yeah, I'll make a phone
call and see if we can get in.
And at the very least, do that.
maybe I'll just try and I don't know,
I'll see what kind of deal I can work,
but that is a hefty price tag, my God.
All right, in other news...
And I want to get you
everything you want, Jonah, gosh darn it.
All right, I'm gonna see what I can do,
picture-wise at least.
All right, some talented woodworkers
are building and giving desks to kids.
What do you know about this?
- Oh yeah, this has been
trending all over the country.
There's woodworkers that
are now making desks
for kids and donating them to them.
And that is so important,
because as a virtual learner myself,
and as so many others are
right now, you need a workspace
your own space to do your school.
And I'm finishing this story off
by letting you know that I love it
when I see under another fellow
human using their handicraft
and their talent to do good for others,
like I do with my crochet.
- I love you Jonah, I
really do, and I agree.
(audience claps)
And we talk so much
about education, Jonah.
And so the fact that these
craftsmen are doing this
for the sake of education, I just,
I know that's a big priority for us.
Okay, you're a crocheting
prodigy, obviously.
What's going on in the crochet news world?
- Well, there's two
stories I'm reporting on.
But the first one is
about "The Golden Girls".
There's now a "Golden Girls" book
where you can crochet "The Golden Girls".
And the one I have my eye on making
is Sophia because she is my
favorite, because she knits.
I mean, I'm primarily a crocheter,
but I do respect those knitters.
- Yeah, absolutely, and you know what?
Fun fact, I think she
was the youngest person
and played the oldest, right?
Estelle Getty.
Yeah, she was actually the
youngest cast member in age,
but played the oldest lady of the group.
Okay, and in other crochet
news, is there one more crochet?
- Oh-
- By the way,
this really gets the lisp in
me, crochet kitty couches.
- Oh yes, this is a big-breaking
news story that's totally-
- I can't wait, bring it on!
- So right now, everybody's
making kitty couches.
And it was originally a pattern
that was made 30 years ago
by my pattern book publisher,
Annie's and the Soul Bouquet.
But in the past couple
months it went crazy.
It went viral on the internet,
and now everybody's making them.
And I had a request to make one
for people from my Instagram,
thousands of requests.
- Really?
- And I never had the time.
But now, I made one and I'm
here to reveal it to you
for the first time.
- And this is a first.
This has never been seen before.
This is Jonah's like premiere kitty couch.
(audience cheers)
Oh my gosh!
Jonah, can I get in line
with the thousands of people?
'Cause we have our two
cats, Lucky and Peach, and-
- Oh, I was just gonna
ask if you had a cat,
but if you genuinely like
it, you could have it.
(audience cheers)
- Are you serious, Jonah?
- Yep, it will be a trade off.
I get my dinosaur picture,
and you get the cat couch.
- Oh my god, Jonah, I'm so excited!
Okay, until next week,
and we're doing some
really amazing reviews
on movies that we both
love, and I can't wait.
And until next week,
Jonah, I will be waiting,
Lucky and Peach, that is a throne.
That is the most fabulous
in cat accoutrement.
Oh my gosh, thank you, Jonah, I love you.
(upbeat music)